President Trump is defending his deal
with Mexico calling off a tariff threat
in exchange for more help keeping
migrants from crossing the southern
border
he's also rejecting reports that some of
the deal was not new and suggesting that
some of it was also secretive chip Reid
is at the White House where new
announcements may be forthcoming chip
where do we go from here
well good morning the president is
already tweeting about this deal this
morning on Sunday he predicted quote
great cooperation between the u.s. and
Mexico but he warned if at if Mexico
falls short he'll go right back to
tariffs Mexico has agreed to accelerate
its National Guard presence on its its
southern border starting today it also
agreed to expand a program requiring
asylum seekers to remain in Mexico while
their claims are being processed the
administration claims this is all new
but former homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen announced the asylum
plan last December both governments have
set a 90-day timeline to see if the
measures are effective and in his tweets
about the deal this morning the resident
tease the possibility of another
immigration and security deal with
Mexico he said it will be revealed in
the not-too-distant future
Anthony all right chip Reid thank you
chip